he's either eight months in or eight
cases deep you know what I'm saying in
the opening scene we are introduced to a
37 year old career obsessed guy named
kintaro hiyama who works as an
advertising agent at unive a company
located in Tokyo kintaro has achieved
notable success in his profession
earning the respect of his colleagues he
schedules everything including his dates
on his calendar in fear of being thrown
off guard in life he is also popular
amongst ladies frequently engaging in
one night stands with them however he
always returns to Aki Sato a 35 year old
freelancer who shares kintaro's
workaholic Tendencies Aki is an
open-minded person who has a rational
approach to decision making prioritizing
logic over emotional impulses the two
are compatible with each other as both
of them share a common thought that they
should not rush into serious
relationships or Parenthood any sooner
in their lives although they are not
officially in a romantic relationship
they maintain a Friends with Benefits
Arrangement based based on Mutual
compatibility one evening kentaro's boss
summons him and his co-workers tanabe
and Suave to discuss a future project at
unive however Suave has to leave early
to look after his child at home as he
departs tanabe makes a comment
suggesting that child care should be
exclusively the responsibility of women
after the dinner kintaro boards a train
to Aki's place where they engage in
Intimate activities following this Aki
resumes her work while kintaro watches
news on TV about male pregnancies this
makes him very uncomfortable Aki
responds by stating that she's not
against having children but she worries
that they might distract her from her
work just then kintaro starts feeling
somewhat uneasy so he decides to take
some rest the next day at work kintaro
presents a proposal centered around
celebrating diversity and individual
identities along with a project slogan
Pride for all people his idea receives a
positive response and he's appointed as
the creative head of the company on the
occasion of his achievement and his
birthday his co-workers surprise him
with a beautiful cake this triggers
memories of his past when he used to
celebrate his birthday with his mother
tomoko he reminisces about how his
mother could only afford a slice of cake
and would quickly return to work after
he blew out the candle as she was the
only one to work fathering his father's
passing as the party ends kintaro feels
a bit light-headed but he doesn't pay
much attention to it and heads home on
his way he receives a call from his
mother wishing him a happy birthday now
that he's financially stable he urges
her to stop driving taxis offering his
support but she refuses to burden her
son the following day kintaro is
discussing the new project with his
co-workers when he suddenly begins to
feel nauseous excusing himself from the
meeting he rushes to the restroom and
vomits worried by this illness from the
last few days kintaro decides to visit a
doctor at the hospital to his
astonishment the doctor reveals that
he's nine weeks pregnant kintaro can't
believe it and so he simply walks away
and Denial on his way home he purchases
a pregnancy testing kit to confirm the
doctor's diagnosis unfortunately the
results confirm his worst fear he is
indeed Prager number shortly after
cantaro receives a call from his boss
who informs him that his proposal has
been accepted and the project is due in
212 days keeping the project
responsibility in mind kintaro goes to
work however while discussing project
related matters he experiences a leak
from his breasts causing his shirt to
become visibly wet one of the co-workers
notices this embarrassing situation
prompting kintaro to quickly rush to the
restroom to clean himself up feeling
disturbed and distracted by these
physical changes kintaro visits the
doctor again with the intention of
seeking an abortion the doctor informs
him that he will need a signed consent
from his partner as well however kintaro
is unaware of who the child's mother is
considering that he's nine weeks
pregnant he checks his calendar and
realizes that it coincides with the time
he had spent the night with Aki implying
that she is the father mother following
this he texts Aki for a meeting but she
declines due to being overloaded with
work in the next scene kintaro starts
Googling information about the male
pregnancy but he is irritated to find
that everything is for women it's all
the same it's just going to come out
your penis moments later his boss
approaches him and invites him for a
sauna bath where he expresses his
concern about kintara's frequent
absences and urges him to take care of
himself to avoid jeopardizing his job
during their conversation the boss
notices the darkened nipple which makes
kintaro uncomfortable prompting him to
leave that evening a weakened kintaro
goes to Aki's place and discloses that
he's pregnant with her child leaving her
in a State of Shock he also requests her
to sign a consent form as he doesn't
wish to proceed with the pregnancy Aki
agrees to sign the form but as kintaro
suddenly feels nauseous he vomits all
over it the next day Aki meets her
pregnant best friend and confides in her
about the situation the latter advises
Aki to carefully reconsider the abortion
decision emphasizing that having a child
is such a wonderful feeling later Aki
meets kintaro for lunch during which he
presents her with another consent form
but this time she hesitates and attempts
to convince him to reconsider his
decision because she wants to have a
child without having to go through the
pregnancy in order to convince him she
highlights potential advantages this
could bring to his professional life but
kentaro refuses asserting that Aki
cannot understand the physical and
emotional toll he's enduring because
it's not her body experiencing it with
no other options Aki ultimately signs
the consent form due to this intense
discussion kentaro gets distracted and
forgets his business meeting schedule
resulting in him missing it as a
consequence his boss transfers
leadership responsibilities to tanabe
now having lost his position kantaro
stays home struggling to adjust to the
pregnant life and away getting the
scheduled abortion procedure the day
arrives when the doctor finally contacts
him to initiate the necessary paperwork
he promptly goes to the hospital where a
nurse informs him that since the fetus
is past 12 weeks it'll be treated as a
stillbirth and that he needs to report
it to the city office for permission to
arrange a burial kentaro is
Thunderstruck by the news of having to
bury his unborn child later while
waiting outside he is approached by a
man named miyaji who is also pregnant
just like him you too huh
the two Bond quickly over their
shared experiences of pregnancy I can't
believe it's gonna hatch out of my pee
hole eventually kintaro reveals his
decision to proceed with the abortion
miyaji understands and shares that he
had considered the same choice but
ultimately decided against it as his
wife is unable to conceive again after
their first child after dinner kantaro
accompanies miyaji to his home where he
meets his wife Noriko and their son
Noriko remarks that miyaji must be happy
to find another pregnant man as he had
initially felt anxious when he
discovered his own pregnancy seeing the
little boy run around kentaro has a
sudden change of mind as he realizes how
precious it is to have a baby the scene
then cuts to a business meeting where
tanabe is leading the discussion however
his presentation proves to be dull
prompting the boss to seek kintaro's
opinion drawing upon his recent
experiences and the advantages
highlighted by Aki kantaro suggests
using a pregnant man for their
advertising campaign initially met with
hesitation from the clients cantaro
boldly steps forward and reveals his own
pregnant displaying his ultrasound and
emphasizing its unique Advantage this
impresses everyone and they become even
more delighted when kentaro volunteers
to be a model for the campaign after
work kentaro mitsaki had a restaurant
and shares his decision to proceed with
the pregnancy he also expresses his
desire to handle it on his own however
Aki assures him that she would love to
help raise the baby and reassures him
that their relationship will remain
unchanged in other words she's still
gonna bang other dudes subsequently
kentaro calls miyaji to inform him of
his decision which fills him with joy
later kintaro also contacts his mother
to share the news but her response
reveals her clear unhappiness about the
situation a few months pass and kintaro
participates in a photo shoot for their
advertising campaign unexpectedly this
gains a lot of attention upon their
release and the campaign becomes a
tremendous success the ads spread
rapidly across social media generating
widespread interest furthermore kintaro
receives invitations to appear on
various shows for interviews but just
like everything has its bad sides
kantaro faces hurtful Prejudice from
people his dating life it's a roadblock
as women refuse to go out with a
pregnant man what if they suck the baby
right out of there the following day
kentaro visits miyaji at his flower shop
and expresses his frustration about not
being able to openly discuss his
pregnancy with anyone miyaji admits that
he also feels the same way as their
conversation unfolds kintaro comes up
with the idea of creating an online
community specifically for pregnant
males where they can share their
challenges and find Solutions together
in the next few days tomoko sees her
son's advertisement on TV and decides to
pay him a visit still upset she
expresses her disappointment that
kentaro didn't even use a pseudonym in
the broadcasts kantaro brushes off her
concerns and instead asks about his
father but tomoko remains silent in the
next scene kintaro appears on a TV show
to discuss unive's project and takes
this opportunity to promote his free
online community for pregnant males he
calls it dickception one afternoon
cantaro and you receive a message from
another pregnant man who wishes to meet
them in person as a result they arranged
their first meeting at a restaurant
which goes very smoothly after the
meeting Cantara goes to miyagi's place
for dinner during which he experiences
the first movements of the baby inside
his belly a few days later kintaro and
Aki visit a shrine to seek blessings for
the upcoming childbirth here we witness
a funny moment when the monk keeps
assuming Aki is the pregnant one on
their way back cantaro and Aki strike up
a discussion and Augie shares a lack of
interest in getting married she doesn't
want to conform to traditional gender
roles amidst their conversation kentaro
receives a call from Noriko informing
him that miyaji has been hospitalized
worried kintaro and Aki rushed to the
hospital only to discover that an
infection has caused miyaji to have a
miscarriage Noriko is devastated by the
loss of her unborn child but finds some
solace in the fact that the baby wasn't
born she discloses about the
mistreatment she has endured from others
and the bullying their son is faced at
school because of miyaji being pregnant
days passed by and cantaro is seen alone
at home at one point he begins to
experience stomach pain prompting him to
visit the hospital upon examination the
doctor informs him that they may expect
a premature birth requiring him to
undergo surgery looks like it's coming
out the bum amidst all this unive
continues to operate smoothly with
kintaro serving as the main Ambassador
during one business meeting cantaro has
taken aback when he sees a baby
documentary featuring his family without
having been consulted about it enraged
kentaro expresses his dissatisfaction
and decides to resign from the company
however his resignation is not accepted
by his boss who goes as far as summoning
the CEO and other directors they praised
cantaro for his efforts in bringing
change in the Society and also remark
that he has become a role model for many
kintaro who has become more sensitive
breaks down in tears and ultimately
decides to stay on the other hand Aki
travels to her parents home to attend
her sister's wedding there she faces
constant nagging from her parents
pressuring her to settle down in life
Aki's mother emphasizes how she
sacrificed her own Ambitions to raise
Aki but she responds by asserting that
today's women no longer need to live in
such a way in the evening Aki meets with
her old school friends many of whom are
already married and have children as
they chat Aki overhears a group of men
at another table discussing kentaro's
advertisement and criticizing a pregnant
men which makes her feel bad that night
wanaki's parents once again bring up the
topic of her marriage she reveals that
she has a boyfriend and they're
expecting a baby her parents are further
confused when Aki clarifies that she's
not the one who's pregnant as expected
her parents struggle to accept this
information so Aki states that she will
start her own family in Tokyo and live
there forever preventing any disgrace to
their family she then proceeds to pack
her belongings and heads to the train
station while waiting for the train she
calls cantaro expressing her desire to
raise the baby together after several
hours Aki arrives in Tokyo and kintaro
goes to pick her up in a cab on their
way back they engage in a heartfelt
conversation where canara expresses the
fear he had thinking of raising the
child alone but now he's happy that they
are together once again the cab first
drops off kintaro at his place where he
comes across a man named aichi waiting
for him aichi introduces himself as
kintaro's father and shockingly also his
mother perplexed kintaro calls his
mother and as soon as she arrives she
impulsively punches aichi in the face
for reappearing tomoko then reveals the
truth that aichi is indeed his father
who had abandoned him when Cantara was
an infant she had kept the secret to
prevent kintaro from potential pain
despite this Revelation kintaro allows
his father to stay with him in his
apartment while his mother drives Aki
home in her taxi during the ride tomoko
apologizes to Aki for having to witness
the strange relationship within their
family but the latter admires her for
raising cantaro alone that night as
aichi comes out from the shower kandaro
notices a scar on his father's stomach
curious he asks if his father really
gave birth to which he says yes he then
recalls how he used to conceal his
pregnancy from the people and it was
challenging even to visit the hospital
but now that he has returned aichi wants
to assist kintara with his online
community project as days pass he
proposes an idea for maternity products
tailored for men impressed by the
concept cantaro suggests involving Aki
and promoting the idea however she shows
no interest and walks away kintaro
follows her attempting to discuss the
matter but their conversation escalates
into a conflict as Aki fears that
kintaro will prioritize his father's
business over their own baby later that
day kintaro meets with his mother who
advises him against working with his
father reminding him of how he had
abandoned them afterwards kintaro
attends a community meeting where he
discovers that his father is already
present and is sharing his business idea
with fellow members meanwhile Aki meets
up with her friend who offers her a job
as an editor for a project in Singapore
however accepting the job would require
her to stay abroad for two years excited
about the opportunity Aki calls kintaro
to share the good news but He suggests
that she declined the offer due to do
her responsibilities towards their
future baby as expected this deeply
saddens Augie the next morning kintaro
wakes up to find himself embroiled in a
fraud Scandal as aichi has disappeared
with the invested money other pregnant
men who had invested in the community
business demand an explanation and the
Press surrounds both the office and his
apartment unable to step out due to the
intense media attention kentaro is
forced to remain at home later his
mother visits and scolds him for not
heeding her advice she speculates today
she may be squandering the money in a
pub despite Aki's attempts to calm him
down kentaro sets out to find his father
fortunately he locates his father in a
van aeichi hands over the money he
collected from everyone and explains
that he had endured immense suffering
back then so running away is all he
knows he just happened to grab all the
money while he was at it he then decides
to quit the project and bids farewell to
kentaro in the morning Aki informs
kintaro that she has decided to accept
the Singapore job she emphasizes that
her decision does doesn't mean that she
is running away from her
responsibilities assuring him that she
will visit him time and again cantaro is
hurt by this news but he conceals his
emotions from showing on his face at
work the higher ranking officials decide
to remove kentaro from the project due
to the Scandal caused by his father in
order to address the situation the
company organizes a press conference
where kintaro explains the complete
story clarifying that he's not involved
in all of this right after speaking to
the public he suddenly collapses and is
immediately rushed to the hospital
meanwhile Aki is at the airport waiting
for her flight and watching the live
broadcast of kintaro's press conference
as soon as she Witnesses his collapse
Aki rushes to the hospital to be by his
side postponing her job opportunity in
Singapore soon after kentaro experiences
intense pain from labor and is taken to
the operating room for the delivery of
their child Aki along with kentaro's
parents anxiously wait outside but
kentaro's not worried he saw Arnie do
this in a movie once it was not so bad
in a moment of remorse aichi upon
apologizes to tomoko for the trouble he
had caused in the past after a while the
operation is successful and kentaro
finally gives birth to a healthy baby
boy the family reunites an award and
aichi gets emotional as he captures a
photograph of his son grandson and Aki
from that day onward kintaro and Aki
take turns caring for and raising their
baby together the online community they
started continues to grow with new
members and pregnant men gradually gain
positive recognition in society now even
girls offer their seats on the train to
pregnant men as a gesture of support one
night tomoko offers to babysit giving
kentaro and Aki the chance to enjoy a
relaxed dinner together during their
meal Aki decides to decline the offer in
Singapore but kentaro urges her not to
do so instead he encourages her to grab
the opportunity without feeling guilty
because he doesn't want her to sacrifice
her dreams just as his mother did for
him finally Aki departs for Singapore in
a few days but she keeps her promise of
visiting them regularly and staying
connected through video calls kintaro
takes pride in what they have
accomplished and remains optimistic that
their baby will grow up to become a
great person under their modern style
family
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching